you gotta put on man and what is the
food like in Mobile like what's the Food
Spot there like oh yeah some good ass
food is it like soul food or whatever
so if we pull up where are you taking me
bro taking your huts chicken hearts
chicken taking out the food sickness
well some taste to that
Godfathers if you like pizza love pizza
um
I'm trying to think stuff we got it
ain't about it again y'all eat a real
alligator over there alligator yeah have
you had alligator yeah I know that
shit's fire
I got a friend we just went somewhere
and he ordered frog legs yeah they said
like chickens they got too many veins
yeah I can't do it July so when I take a
fruit alligator yeah but but the
difference is it was like nuggets
it was like a breaded alligator nugget
nah I hope I could eat it in like that I
can't eat it just in really good yeah
yeah I don't I don't like to me the Frog
thing you see the frog legs and you're
like man that's a [__] Lake nah yeah
but it looked like a chicken though see
I if I know it's a frog I ain't [__]
with that right what you know as a
chicken
but I see I'm my Society has
desensitized me uh it made me okay with
eating a chicken all right
like a frog could be my homie yeah I
mean I got a pet Frog as a kid yeah I
was really cute one with my frog at
daycare oh really what I had a pet frog
named Fat Joe I think my [__] name uh
little TJ or something did uh because yo
taking care of a frog is tough for
people don't know this [__] cage can
smell right do you ever have a turtle
though
oh well he probably died from starvation
and from I don't know he probably ran
out of breath well he might die from
both of them and I fought up 99 Jimmy
Jimmy the Frog yeah see I see that's why
I can't eat a frog you can eat Jimmy
can't you can't eat Jimmy I don't have a
pet [__] cow bro I'll eat a burger
you know what I'm saying yeah no but the
alligator nuggets if you ever go to
Houston go to Pappadeaux's and they got
alligator nuggets them shits are amazing
I'm gonna try one uh not bad yeah I've
never tried you know what another thing
that I tried that I didn't see it and I
was straight into eating no not squirrel
that's some Alabama [__] for sure
uh rattlesnake
nah
I didn't know it was and then I ate it
and I was like oh what's that chicken
that's different they're like that's a
snake
a rattlesnake bro they'd be serving that
[__] you had a squirrel no ain't no
Adam's World well I know for each
squirrels do they eat that [__] in
Alabama some of them I eat squirrel I
heard somebody squirrel for
did you see the Alabama fight that
happened on the on the pier yeah
somebody sent me that the other day this
is one of the craziest fights we've ever
captured on video in American history
what and it happened in your home state
yeah my grandma Yeah Montgomery how far
is that from you about two out of 30
minutes yeah that shit's insane
yeah that my guy was out there like
[__] like mankind bro in 98 WWE just
cracking fools with the chair bruh 100